PROFESSOR: Understanding
proofs includes the ability
to spot mistakes in them.
And as a test of
that skill and also
your understanding
of induction, let
me see if I can put
one over on you.
I'm going to show you a
bogus proof by induction.
And I'm going to prove something
that's patently absurd.
Namely, that all horses
have the same color.
Say they're all black.
So, there's a bunch of
black horses with maybe
some highlighted brown manes.
I'm going to prove
this by induction.
And for a start, there's no
n mentioned in the theorem,
so that's common for
various kinds of things
that you need to
prove by induction.
So I have to rephrase
it in terms of n.
It's going to be
by induction on n.
The induction
hypothesis is going
to be that any set consisting
of exactly n horses
will all have the same color.
Let's proceed to prove this.
Now, I'm going to use the base
case n equals 1, just because I
don't want to distract you with
suspicions that the base case
n equals 0, that is no
horses, is cheating somehow.
It would be, in fact, be
perfectly legitimate to start
with n equals 0 and argue that
all the horses in the empty set
have the same color,
because there's
nothing in the empty set.
However, let's
not get into that.
We'll start with n equals one.
And indeed, if you look
at any set of one horse,
it is the same color
of it as itself.
And in fact, I've proved
the base case n equals 1.
Let's keep going.
Now, in the inductive
step, I'm allowed
to assume that n horses
have the same color, where
n is any number greater
than or equal to 0.
Now right here, students
complain that that's not fair,
because you're already
assuming something false
and that's absurd.
Well, yeah, it is absurd.
But that can't be the problem.
I'm just allowed to assume
an induction hypothesis.
All I have to do is prove
that n implies n plus 1.
Since it's absurd,
there ought to be
some problem with the proof.
Well, let's watch
and see if there's
a problem with the proof.
So again, I can assume
that any set of n horses
have the same color.
I have to prove that any
set of n plus 1 horses
have the same color.
How will I do that?
Well, there's a set
of n plus 1 horses,
and let's consider the
first n of those horses.
Now by induction hypothesis,
the first n of them
have the same color.
Black, maybe.
Also by induction hypothesis,
the second set of n horses--
that is, all but the first
horse-- have the same color.
And what that tells me is that
the first and the last horse
have the same color as all
of the horses in the middle.
And therefore, in fact, they
all have the same color.
End of proof, QED.
So, there had better
be something wrong.
And what's wrong?
Well, what's wrong is
that the proof that P of n
implies P of n plus 1 is wrong.
It looked good, but
the proof that P of n
implies P of n plus 1 has to
work for all n greater than
or equal to the base case.
And if you look
at this proof, it
doesn't work in the base case.
When n is 1 and you're trying
to go from the base case
to two and so on by implication,
the proof breaks down.
Because what happens with
our argument in the case
that we're trying to prove
that P of n implies P of n
plus 1 in the case that n
equals 1, well in that case,
there aren't any middle horses.
N plus 1 is 2, so
there's a first horse.
And that's the first n horses.
And then the second half of set
of n horses is the other horse,
and there are no middle
horses that they both have
a color in common with.
So, the proof just broke there.
But, you might not have
noticed because that was
the only place it was broken.
This is a case where we were
misled by ellipsis, by the way.
Where because I was
drawing n plus 1 horses
with-- showing a lot of horses
with dots in the middle,
it looked like there were some.
But they weren't.
And again, as I said,
the point though
is that the only
fallacy in this proof
was that it didn't
work when n was one.
But it certainly
worked for implying
that if all sets of two
horses are the same, that does
imply that all sets of three
horses are the same color.
And again, it's a false,
we'll imply anything,
kind of example.
But even here, the
proof was logically OK.
But if it breaks in
one place, if there's
one domino that's missing from
the line when the one before it
falls, the rest of
them stop falling
and the proof breaks down.